hello everybody I wanted to take a
moment out of my normal schedule to
really just personally thank you
everyone who subscribed to me and helped
me out and believed in me so far I
really don't feel like I ever say that
enough I really don't because it hit me
this morning when I woke up that I
actually have thirty five thousand
subscribers and that may not be a big
number to you if you just walked in
recently that may just be you know you
thought I had that but that is an
amazing thing for this channel that is
amazing thing for me because this
channel specifically only started about
five months ago my original channel only
started about seven months ago two
months before that and the growth and
the amazing response that I've gotten
from people and the the letters and not
letters but emails and messages that I
get every day that I can't respond to
all of them and I really read that a
candidate's it's all just you know it's
overwhelming at times to know that some
people actually believe in me this much
um it's just unbelievable to understand
that people spend hours of their life
you know just watching me trying to be
entertaining and I hope that I'm
succeeding in at least a little bit
because I want to be worthy of your time
so thank you all thank thank you truly
from the bottom of my heart I cannot
thank you enough I want to thank you
each individually but but I I mean I I
just believe that we can do so much more
with what we have and the road where
we're going what we're doing with what
we have so far the money that we've
raised for charity
is truly incredible so thank you really
thank you so much for believing in me
and I want to be worthy of
if I want to improve myself every day if
you're new to this channel and you want
to find out more about me if you just
subscribe because you saw a nice video
or something you thought was funny check
out this video which is my 10,000
subscriber video it it's one where I try
to reintroduce myself to everyone tell
you a little bit about me and my past
and where I've come from and how I've
gone from not doing anything and
entertaining to um actually potentially
being an influential figure not a
celebrity by any chance I have to have a
huge ego to think that but just I can't
believe that my goals are actually
happening and it's all thanks to you for
sharing my videos with your friends and
passing along the word because without
you I would be nothing I would I would
just be a guy on the internet but now
I've got thousands I can literally say
ten tens of thousands I've gone up a
scale of ten and it's incredible it's
truly an honor to be able to do this
every day for your entertainment and
also um check out this other video I'm
gonna link here it's my twenty thousand
subscriber video from my fans this is
what I'm talking about when I say that
I'm I'm humbled every day because I get
these kind of messages and these kind of
videos every day and it's it's it's just
it's the greatest feeling in the world
I never ever ever want to take advantage
of it I never want to take advantage of
it
I just wanted to improve myself every
day I never wanna you know change who I
am for other people I'm just gonna be
Who I am at all all times and I hope
that's entertaining enough for the
masses but even if it's not it's
entertaining for you guys so far and if
you guys like what I do I'm only going
to try to improve myself so thank you
honestly thank you so much you have done
more than you know and together we're
going to do absolutely incredible things
so thank you all from the bottom of my
heart thank you
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye